[Music]
Michael Robb and I this morning came in
to play call of duty 2 3 in world war
just kind of the more recent World War 2
call duty games leading up to the
release sledgehammer and Activision's
release of call duty world war 2 the
next installment coming out November was
to release a third thank you and so we
wanted to kind of get Kelly's take she
saw a lot more behind closed doors it's
up now on the site write your
impressions so go read that after the
stream or right now while we're kind of
talking about it here I want to get
impressions of that stuff but then I
also kind of want to move on to a
broader discussion about whether we even
want to go back to World War 2 um my
answer has changed since I watched the
trailer today I'm not like super
negative not to get into that yet but um
it's worth talking about yeah I was
whelmed by it just like who said well
somebody was a reddit comment he said
wow I've got this off you don't threw me
off just while we're watching the
trailer oh he was right there at that
master what's his name Josh Duhamel Josh
Duhamel the last thing I saw him and was
the black Donnelly's very short-lived I
think FX show about this Irish family
that takes over the Irish mob in Boston
that's dope
it was really good it got cancelled but
that was blessing I saw man what else is
he in anything you know armours that's
what it is okay thank you I do you
talking about
yeah uh but anyway uh Kelly let us know
what you there except their stuff you
still can't talk about Arthur no it's
all right yes laughs on that wink uh I
went to sledgehammer um to see some
behind-the-scenes stuff and so I mean
this trailer is very much a Call of Duty
trailer but I got to see a couple of
missions and actions so obviously
there's a Normandy mission we saw that
and then a Herc and forest which is
known for the Germans would do tree
bursts which is when they would put
artillery into the trees to create
shrapnel that would rain down on the US
soldiers and so I got to see that
sequence as well
ouch um yeah and the reason it worked so
well is because US soldiers were trained
to when they heard artillery to fall
flat like on their stomachs and that
made them huge targets for shrapnel
um and so yeah so first I want talk
about Normandy I think the the biggest
hang-up I had is like I've seen Normandy
done we've all seen Normandy done it's
an iconic the world war two moment for
sure um but there's this this one
section that really stuck out to me and
it's when you're playing this like 19
year old recruit who's like a private in
the fighting first from Texas from some
state and yeah sure Texas it is he says
at the end of the trash tamela's from
his character from Oklahoma so I still
had that my head um
but yeah basically you're kind of going
up the beach as you do and he has the
Bangalore torpedo um and he fumbles it
like you just can't get it to work and I
liked moving on from previous college eb
games mean sledgehammers previous being
advanced warfare and then i played a lot
of black ops 3 and not so much infinite
but it's like it's nice to it return to
something or you're not overpowered
super soldier like feeling like this
this is a kid who was thrown into this
war and it's that little detail that
made this game like made me optimistic
about it like oh i like that they're
kind of acknowledging that most these
these guys were you know 17 18 19 no
training a week of basic and they went
to war and it seems like they're they're
trying to treat that with a lot of
respects and not over glorify this war
which has been over glorified for years
and years and years so that stuck out to
me and then the Huracan sequence is
actually super cool and just when the
shrapnel is raining down it was like
reverberating in my chest we did watch
it in the theater so that the sound
system was good but um yeah so I wrote
all about that and how those little
details could really set this apart
did you so is it gonna be the same
character for throughout the whole
playthrough
um actually yeah yes that's one of the
things I was most excited about that I
didn't write about too much because it's
not new for call of duty um finest hour
did this but uh you switch perspectives
to a female French Resistance fighter so
it's a sniper sequence sort of like the
Russian sniper in finest hour
and um she it sounds like it's gonna be
there all Gilad up basically it's just
like a slower stealthier sequence but I
was really excited because I went into
this Bing like it's World War 2 I don't
know if there will be any playable women
and then it was like just kidding here's
play with women for multiplayer and
singleplayer and so I was I was actually
really excited about that but it's
mostly following the 1st Infantry
Division gotcha
uh yeah it's a big red one called duty
big red one did it before but it's
interesting to see because I think a lot
of the World War two things we've seen
least from the American perspective is
like these elite soldiers Saving Private
Ryan there were Rangers Band of Brothers
they're the one Oh first paratroopers
airborne and then obviously you know you
have like Marines in the Pacific but the
fact that these are like draftees you
said yeah they're two weeks of training
that'll be interesting and usually not
people who wanted to be there didn't
really you know particularly say I want
to go into training so I have someone
well trained in the foxhole next to me
yeah um curious see how they do that cuz
the trailer did not give me that
impression everybody the trailers like
let's get to work
I was like you [ __ ] see that's the
thing that that disappointed me so much
about the trailers the trailers very
like Rock Call of Duty word
yeah war and I didn't get that sense
from anything I saw while I was there or
anybody I talked to I mean the whole
team did so much research and immerse
themselves in like super upsetting
details about World War two and they had
this military advisor and everyone
seemed really dedicated to it when I
talked to them and of course part of
that is like of course you're going to
talk about that first and foremost um
but the the Normandy Seabees in
particular just doesn't feel like the
trailer makes the game seem and granted
this is hands off I saw gameplay I
didn't actually play it so that's
subject to change but my impression is
very different from what the trailer
creates and it seems like it's catering
to like but the idea of what a Call of
Duty fan is and when I think of Call of
Duty going back to its roots I mean I
remember playing the originals and I
just I've never considered myself part
of that demographic um and so it's like
you know it seems like the game itself
doesn't isn't trying as hard to to cater
to that but the trailer was just so it's
just so you know okay
it's too familiar yeah we've seen like
we were talking when we did like a
little bit of a breakdown I don't want
to see Omaha Beach again I don't see
Utah Beach right it mean there are a
couple shots that are clearly influenced
by some PI Ryan don't like the shoulder
the shoulder silhouette the governor
it's the fact that they hop up the right
side of the landing craft into the water
like that whole shot was just straight
from the movie so it's you see that and
you go yeah I mean I know what all this
means I know you know what I know that
move everyone knows that scene is almost
you know culturally impacted uh
impactful scenes of like you know cinema
history like it's just it was such a big
deal so yes they're gonna pull from that
um but again just yeah hearing you talk
about it
Kali is is is great because I needed to
hear that I needed to hear a different
like take yeah other than looking all
these familiar shots again this is not
the trailer we yeah I mean just to to
conclude that thought from what I was
saying earlier it's like the the details
and the attention to detail that I saw
in the sequences that that I got to see
that weren't in this trailer are what
could set it apart from being the same
old the same scenes we've always seen um
and so that's what my hope is there but
do you think that you know they're going
for these Saving Private Ryan Eska
moments that are almost like ripped from
the film if you think about it that
movie is almost 20 years old right and
so do you feel like they're trying to
make something for a younger generation
where it's like you know these older
games that we made you probably haven't
played it so we're gonna kind of show
that side World War 2 again but for a
different you know different generation
yeah actually 20 years that is a great
question I knew it all right um know one
of the oh sorry hold on a second how old
are you I'm 26
you're feeling old yeah you're younger
than me man no I didn't say a feeling
all right there anyway um no I hid these
days I talked to the animation director
and he basically said that exact thing
is like there's
a whole generation who didn't really
have the same like World War two media
experience that kind of all of us did
and so that's part of kind of I don't
think it's going to be like a greatest
hits of all the World War two missions
everyone loves it but because that would
be my ultimate nightmare and I hate that
um but it does seem like they're they're
trying to reintroduce this for people
for cause like one of the guys I talked
to you like has an eight-year-old kid
and this kid is like yeah dad we learned
about World War two in school but like
has no context for any of it because
it's been 20 years
Sandra Saving Private Ryan it's been 10
years since the last World War 2 Call of
Duty so that's that's might be what the
like hitting those familiar scenes
that's why support I feel like
sledgehammer and Trey arcs and infinity
war eventually started going futuristic
because they didn't have the I don't
know political ramifications cuz called
to be the modern warfare series was
based it was fictional but it was based
on real events I mean after no Russian
like what are you well I mean even the
first game it was Afghanistan and Iraq
while this war was happening that's in a
lot of ways I [ __ ] up it was a fun
game and I loved that game but that's
still like that war it was nowhere out
of our minds and always was still it
wasn't it wasn't ever declared war it
was a conflict but you want to actually
say when you go they got like iraqi
freedom they depicted that it was kind
of weird so they went to the future
games but now they're kind of going back
to antiquity now that World War 2 is
coming back around I feel like yeah void
may be some sort of ramification and
kind of push back I don't know yeah I I
mean I feel like you can still get
pushback from glorifying uh you know
World War 2 or not showing like you know
there's my hope is that you know you
have German soldiers who are kids the
same way the US soldiers are and they're
different from the SS right like I want
to see that and he wants and like if
they if they didn't do that I would be
like all right well this is just another
rehash of like go America
so I mean it's difference it the the
push back would be different from you
know doing a war that is currently being
waged but is there any any hint to that
from the event you went to that you know
there might be more humanization
your enemy or other people with and that
you at war with because then I feel like
one of the more impactful moments like
we've all watched Band of Brothers
Saving Private Ryan
but then the behind the scenes Band of
Brothers stuff where they interview
these soldiers I own the early 2000s
they're like you know I remember I
forgot his name but he was he was
depicted in banner brothers but he was
like winners no I wasn't winners moves
like shifty powers powers of sniper yeah
he got in the plane crash on the way
back after the war was done oh yeah he
survived yeah yeah and then he was like
what if the I went fishing with that guy
that Germans sold all my kills
absolutely yeah I would have been good
friends cuz we just want a little
powerful piece and you know go fishing
and just enjoy nature but you know we
had to kill each other for this war like
I still haven't seen that trade very
much in video games not that I'm like
you know asking someone to do that but
you know if you're gonna go back to this
there's a lot of nuance that you can
incorporate now that we've played so
many of these games that are more of
like glorification of war and the big
scenes like d-day and operation Market
Garden battle the Bulge and we've seen
that but where else can we go with that
setting yeah that's why I want to ask
you guys I guess I could just go down
the line I don't know if you guys have
certain ideas but Rob do you have any
ideas what you want them to do specific
fronts USC missions uh it looks like
it's gonna be its American squad but
theater Western Front mostly 4445 ground
missions in Europe uh bowel bulge
I feel like isn't because I that was a
horrifying battle I mean just you know
holding those lines during the winter
and I went through like I'd like to see
how that could be depicted now again
like with all the humanizing tones like
just you know how the band brothers did
the the best portrayal of that like you
know how they had like get up and push
yeah and they're they have frostbite
yeah my supplies warm no supplies
they're just dropping in the environment
anything like that I think would be
really interesting uh and I I like that
I'm curious to know how I would end
right because I mean historically
America the Americans in hit
right the Russians hit Berlin before us
so it's like how will how will this wrap
up and again I'll have to touch on
banner brothers his band brothers and
did very you know that we talked about
the last two episodes of like that
series was more about like how the
soldiers like were holding themselves
after the war where shiftee was the one
who said that how am I gonna explain
this to people back home yeah how are
they like there's still the war is over
and they're still like like you know we
in occupied Germany they're like
fighting each other for the most part
like you know I'm like comrades and
everything but yeah I really curious to
see what route they take yeah I know
about you too Michael
I mean I when they announced that call
dudes come back to World War two I was
like huh maybe I really do want to like
see this again because I grew up like
studying this stuff and it's been a long
time since I thought about World War two
I mean you know I read a lot of books
Stephen Ambrose and and Tom Brokaw like
their books of World War two were part
of you know my interest in this at a
young age and then now that I'm older I
can kind of like contextualize all that
stuff and I play a lot of video games I
would like to see some of that more
in-depth stuff portrayed at least in the
game you know if this is going to be I
mean I understand from reading your
preview that it's going to be you know
you're playing this guy and you have a
tight-knit squad and it's more about at
least from what I got from your previews
that like not just the war but the war
within himself well so it sounds like
yeah like having to deal with this major
conflict at such a young age like that's
cool
I think that that if they if that's
executed correctly or well enough like
that that'll be enough to hold my
interest but at this point you know I
want to see different environments I
want to see parts of the war that I may
not know about and but I'm gonna you
know I'm gonna play through this and see
what it has to offer
yeah I think the biggest thing for me is
they really stress like wanting to put
you in like they wanted to put you in
that situation like make you feel like
you were there I don't think that any
piece of media can act can really do
that and I also want to see the like
ramifications of
or executed properly one of my favorite
novels when I was younger was a separate
piece and I liked that because it was
never about the the war I mean was set
during the war but it was more about
people and it sounds like I mean this is
a very character-driven story but if
it's not executed properly I think it
can really just fall totally flat and so
I just haven't seen enough of character
or of like the plot or narrative around
them to really get a feel for that and
that's like my biggest unanswered
question you guys think like Call of
Duty is the franchise that would be the
first one to really portray war in a
meaningful way I mean I fit if you like
it's a bit like Call of Duty like I
don't I can't even stress out every time
I look at numbers it's insane I mean
like we know it sells well I'm we're not
done but like it's it's huge do you
think something this big would take that
risk
I mean well that's how they they started
so they have that foundation to but
that's not how they started they started
we called what 2003 was called duty and
that was just like that wasn't they
didn't say anything meaningful about
that they just straight World War 2 I
don't think they ever have I mean like
pre-release for infinite warfare they're
like we're gonna put you list we're
gonna show you what it means to I mean
I'm just beat double down yeah but I
think they have to we talk about how
tired like I mean the the hey you're
tired of we I think they have to I think
yeah I think like it you can't they
can't just fall back and do the exact
same thing again no so there's one thing
that they could do differently hmm is is
what we're talking about exactly like
otherwise everything adds up to like
it's it has to add up to something or
else it's what's the point right to make
however like a billion dollars yeah I
forgot about money and yeah I mean I'm
again I'm just playing devil's FK I
would love that basically tell like I'm
so well made story but I think the
battlefield one when they were showing
their trailer and everything and they're
like we're it's really gonna be about
the causes of the people that take place
in the war but it's not it was they made
you look heroic you're into this the
[ __ ] suit of armor coming across a
battlefield with the machine gun like
they're not I mean again I'm just I'm
just think it's my instinct to hear this
PR stuff and say okay well let's wait
until November and then I'll my doubt
called it he's going to do it but it can
still be fun I'm not saying it's not
going to be like I want to ask you about
multiplayer and loadouts which is
completely contrary to when we're
talking about
all right it's still I have a hard time
listening to Activision sledgehammer
saying they're gonna do that when I
almost positive they won't oh yeah I
mean they can say that they want to do
that what from what I saw there's
potential for them to do that yes is
basically um what my preview is about
but yeah if you wanna talk multiplayer
we know very little
yeah um to move on to less to lighter
stuff yeah yeah
what do you know about multiplayer um do
they even say anything at the event
barely I mean we we saw the the teaser
image like that two-second thing from
that the livestream was more than I saw
at the event um basically the the one
thing is there the big thing that stood
out to me was they're adding a new
called war mode and it's supposed to be
like narrative driven access versus
allies iconic World War two battles so
it's I figure out the mode is called in
battlefield one operations yes yes um
and so it sounded sort of in that vein
um but I don't know anything else about
it and did look the other weird thing
was that they're doing something called
headquarters which is like a social
space that sounds like Destiny's Tower
um we're uh
Titan falls titanfall 2 uh their Lobby
systems yeah what I called it was a clan
system well forget it's called remember
but okay sorry go if this sounds more
like in a menu the sons it's like an
actual walking space it's that's what it
sounds like
oh cool location so not a multiplayer
Lobby but like a plate like and it was
like you get rewards and recognition I'm
like is that a cool outfit like what
does that mean that sounds so good but
overall like that time setting but it's
like I'm never gonna get into a
multiplayer matches hangout HQ [ __ ]
fighting I just want to hear a little
kid singing frozen songs
like it's just gonna be like a tourism
watch yeah yeah so not sure what that
means again very few details the other
thing was like others divisions it
sounds like classes like oub Infantry
Division or Armored Division and then of
course take a shot everytime they say
boots on the ground that was the other
bullet point was boots on the ground
game play so obviously like that means
TDM and all that stuff most likely I
would you would shock me if you were
like oh yeah they got rid of team
deathmatch be like that you're stupid so
um yeah yeah whole lot of I do want to
talk about the coop teaser that they
they show oh [ __ ] yeah I didn't see any
of that I figured it was going to be
something zombies related but yeah they
basically show a nazi zombie this will
be the first time sledgehammer would
have done zombies cuz last well they did
next Asami's oh they did that eggs the
dumb one is gone no they've done that
dance work yeah but in terms of like
zombies like infinite warfare because
Infinity Ward for the first time did it
with infinite warfare right uh some is
almost basically it was their first
Sarris for a and so this wouldn't be
sledgehammers first but it would be more
in line with Treyarch zombies again I
mean like that's the impression I got
from the one image they showed and the
fact that they were like gods about the
Third Reich doing stuff I was like
alright that sounds like stuff yeah it
sounds like me oh my god Mike wanted to
talk about wolf ins we just got
triggered you know Segway on purpose no
no sorry finish your coffee
that's all because I'm so excited cuz
Rob looks really mad
listen no I'm more mad he I'm not do I
never you mind never said you were being
a good lump right now I never said that
new order was better than calf will
Castle Wolfenstein why are we talking
because it is the most it is the best
most recent World War 2 game even though
it's alternate history I didn't say has
to be historical dang a throw hands
might say I don't like Castle
Wolfenstein might deal well the sideline
you order is one of the best shooters in
the last do I like poison
yeah oh my god the band
sorry ways co-op in
Call of Duty World War two has excited
because of the third right deal I
wouldn't say I'm excited I'm just I
wanted to talk about it reading I'm I'm
they didn't say anything at the events
that was like a surprise to me during
this live stream um yeah so they showed
one picture of a zombie looking dude and
they're like this is co-op and I mean
that's to be expected but I'm interested
I should say to see what they do with it
I'd be interested to see like how much
money they make off like zombies DLC but
maybe there's making so much off that
they're like all three Studios have to
do zombies now it's very community man
there is a strong I love some sites
I love zombies ooh it's gain so much
momentum that yeah I wonder if they like
cannot now sorry they have to do a
zombies every time we were talking about
modern warfare two's spec ops co-op
stuff I really liked that I was hoping
for that or it and to have it more of a
narrative versus like you know off
missions like stealth like there are
some good ones in those spec ops like as
far as teamwork goes great buddy I mean
who'd be like that we don't know
anything about how it'll actually play
out they just showed we have the story
on the site now I think they just showed
an image of a zombified great dude um so
who knows if it's going to be like they
said it was gonna be a new story so it
could be more story different I don't
know okay we don't know a whole lot
about those two things we know I'm the
most about single-player so nazi zombies
are returning nah they're already here
right now like here no fair yeah yeah
that'd be a sick way to end this it was
nice to know ah yes November third Call
of Duty World War 2 I'm sure we'll know
more in the coming months especially III
on the horizon I don't know if they're
doing a Call of Duty xp event again Don
LA um oh yeah I keep forgetting we were
both there because yeah yeah um I didn't
really enjoy that yeah no um Activision
I noticed hmm yeah uh no but the oh I
guess I should mention that the
multiplayer will be playable on the show
for at e3 oh cool so that might mean
there's no Call of Duty XP because III
is open to the public this year so
that's sort of the opportunity for them
to show that off to fan
so yeah I mean we'll learn more about
multiplayer and presumably co-op around
III cool sweet so November 3rd will be
called Duty World War 2 on ps4 Xbox one
PC as usual from sledgehammer it's their
turn with the Call of Duty franchise for
the year before it goes back to Treyarch
next year if they keep that trend going
which I'm sure they will because I'm
sure this game will make a lot of money
we'll see how it goes I'm excited to see
more about multiplayer the trailer I
think a little lukewarm on I think I got
too many battlefield 1 Saving Private
Ryan manor brothers vibes I want to see
the booty shot it was a very yeah yeah
it was a very very or like Dunkirk even
now you know the Stukas the propellers
and stuff is cool I'm cool I'm looking
forward to seeing more from it but let
us know what you think let us know
whether your planned if this is going to
pull you back to the call 2d franchise
if you've been away for it from a while
from it for a while let us know what you
think and if you're in the chat here
while we wrap up let us know what you
think leave your thoughts in the
comments below if you're watching this
on youtube or GameSpot after the fact
[Music]